secur now below with all haste I will go
and I will go inside
[Music]
Final Fantasy has always been about
reinvention and final fantasy 12
embodies this to such an extreme that
you might wonder even for a second if
this is really a Final Fantasy game
not only is it deserving of the name but
it's an RPG through and through we're
story driven exploration of spacious
locales and monster hunting effectively
feed into its stat base progression
within an ensemble cast of colorful
personalities as with every final
fantasy before it 12 puts its own spin
on how chocobos summons and character's
name Sid play into its epic journey with
its remastered - zodiac age file fantasy
12 puts its best foot forward with a
wealth of improvements and changes
delivering a fresh experience even if
you know how to go from the fog coast to
the tomb of Wraith wall without a map
for those who've religiously played the
ps2 version allow fancy 12 the zodiac
age is not only a remaster but also a
remix keen eyes will notice subtle
tweaks to enemy locations and even
changes to the selection of merchant
goods some of these modifications are in
service in the character enhancing
License Board which itself has been
overhauled from the original game in
order to give each party member more
distinctive abilities along with the
inclusion of a Japanese voice track and
improved loading times the option to
toggle between the original andrey
orchestrated versions of hitoshi
sakimoto x' exquisite soundtrack is a
welcome feature
lastly the improved high-definition
visuals brings out a fetching painterly
look to the characters faces the
Imperial stole it from us so it's only
fair that we take it back it's our duty
as Dom askins further driving the
distinctiveness of five has C 12 is its
setting of Ivelisse an established
universe with its origins outside of the
numbered Final Fantasies and like other
games based in Ivelisse specifically
vagrant story and FAL Fantasy Tactics 12
Splott often feels like a middle chapter
of a grander tale yet to be told sort of
a traitor your trust is soared we must
trade or no I see no other way two
kingdoms dalmasca and abroad you are
caught in a crossfire of to larger
warring empires
Rosaria and arcadia of the countless
individuals affected by this period of
upheaval six characters all of whom come
from vastly different backgrounds form
your party uniting for a common cause to
de-escalate this continent-wide conflict
perpetuating this middle episode vibe
are the playable characters themselves
who have been appropriately compared to
the cast of Star Wars a new hope as
examples Ashe is the captured princess
and Bosch is the former general in
hiding while fear is the self-serving
pirate with a price on his head
and his partner fron has been described
as sexy Chewbacca they're intertwined
backstories and resulting encounters
allow for chemistry and conflict as the
off
engaging narrative unfolds the zodiac
age punctuates file fancy twelves
timelessness with the distinctive gambit
battle system by stringing together a
series of if-then commands for each
character battles unfold with a
semi-automated flow where you can
vanquish beasts without pressing a
button for minutes on end one would
think that this would deprive you of
agency and engagement but the gambit
system in fact creates the opposite
result since you're still responsible
for every characters actions the thrill
of seeing your handiwork unfold and
emerging victorious never gets old it
allows for experimentation and
risk-taking but the gambit system truly
shines when you stick to sensible and
tried-and-true RPG battle tactics
remember all those times you died in
battle because you ignored a status
ailment and thought you can get one last
attack in instead this system removes
all manner of impulsive miss and for
many offers a 100-hour glimpse of the
RPG combatant one aspires to be free of
impetuous behaviors
you don't get your hands on this
mechanic and earnest until three hours
in which is one hour too many yet
getting on board is a notably improved
experience over the original game thanks
to the option to double or even
quadruple the speed of play this is just
one of many new features that makes the
zodiac age ever more engrossing in a
game that features responding enemies
every hostile area becomes increasingly
inviting when you're motivated by
growing your party stats at an
accelerated pace while its enhancements
do not translate into a brand new
experience for existing fans foul
fantasy 12 the zodiac age is nonetheless
invigorating it's epic lore abundant
story and its time-tested gambit system
should appeal to those who missed out on
five as a 12 the first time around and
thanks in part to the new audio and
speed options the zodiac age is an ideal
definitive edition one that improves the
game over its original version across
the board
[Music]